No, I don't need help.
What's going on? Hello world,
it's Saroj and one of the most popular
services for cloud computing is
Microsoft's Azure.
It's got everything.
A business needs to run all parts
of its computing operations,
virtually meaning servers,
storage, analytics, Api Apis,
all that stuff.
I'll use it to predict the price of a car
using it's drag and drop interface and
if you're new here,
hit the subscribe button to keep up
with my AI content in this age of cloud
computing, it's crazy to think
that just over a decade ago,
if we wanted to serve a
website to people on the web,
we had to build and manage the physical
hardware needed for computing like
servers,
red bull and Ethernet switches.
Now it's all about renting the
hardware resources as we need it.
This pay as you go model has been
wildly successful with most major cloud
providers now offering it. If we look
at the marketplace for cloud computing,
it's clear that a zero is only
surpassed by AWS in quarterly revenue.
Another incredible statistic is that 85%
of fortune 500 companies from a Yoda to
NBC universal use Azure.
Clearly Microsoft dominates
in the enterprise market.
Most of their servers are running
windows anyway and Azure makes that
integration very simple.
Uh,
zero has its own version
of all the standard cloud
services available under the
categories of compute, storage, databases,
networking Api Apis, each with
a unique name, even blockchain.
What I've attached a sheet that maps out
every service name to its competitors
to help familiarize yourself
with what each tool does.
It'll be in the video description, but
what makes a zero unique? It's blue.
Well,
for starters it's dedication to the
hybrid cloud is definitely worth noting.
A private cloud is a set of computing
services that are offered either over the
internet or a private internal network
and only to select users instead of the
general public. This can also be
called an internal or corporate cloud.
This gives businesses the benefits of
a public cloud like elasticity and self
service with the additional customization
and control available from a dedicated
computing infrastructure
hosted on premises.
And don't forget the leveled up security
that a company can implement through
both company firewalls and
internal hosting to ensure
that sensitive data is not
accessible to third party providers.
The con here is that private clouds
require the same staffing management and
maintenance expenses as
traditional data center ownership.
A hybrid cloud allows a business to take
advantage of cloud bursting to free up
more space and scale computing
services to the public cloud.
When computing demands increase,
hybrid clouds are easier with a zero
because Microsoft for saw the need for
hybrid clouds early on,
we can use onsite servers
to run our applications on
the Azure stack and set our
computing resources to tap into
cloud based resources when necessary.
Several a zero offerings like the hybrid
CQL server and a zero store simple help
with this. Microsoft's a long
history of working on enterprise.
It gives them this edge,
but let's talk about its machine learning
offerings since that's what we care
about the most.
A [inaudible] machine learning
offering has five components,
a workbench and experimentation service,
a model management service,
a set of libraries and visual
studio tools for AI. Together.
A developer can use these tools to train
and deploy machine learning models in
the cloud on premise or at the edge.
It fully supports open sores,
python libraries so we can use tensorflow,
psychic learn,
Pi Torch and others to build our models
and experiments can be executed in a
managed environment like
a docker container or a
spark cluster with plenty of
gps to help accelerate execution.
It's custom.
M M L spark framework provides integration
with Apache spark and their cognitive
toolkit as well as open CV.
This lets developers quickly
create scalable predictive
models for large images
and text datasets.
They've got some extensive documentation
about this in their get hub repository,
which is pretty lit.
Spark by the way,
is a unified analytics engine for machine
learning developed at UC Berkeley a
decade ago.
Big companies have rapidly adopted
and deployed spark at massive scale
collectively processing
petabytes of data on clusters,
over 8,000 nodes and in the process
helped make it one of the largest open
source communities on the web.
It's a framework for
efficiently processing large
amounts of data in parallel.
It's built in libraries for ml are well
made and it turns out to be much easier
to work with than traditional
MapReduce and with project brainwave,
you can deploy your model to be
trained on not just a CPU or GPU,
but if field programmable
gate array or FPGA,
this is a customized circuit that's
highly efficient and flexible.
A trained neural network can be run as
quickly as possible on an FPGA and can
you me paralyzed across multiple ones?
The scale of service,
it makes it possible to
achieve low latency for real
time inferencing requests.
Microsoft made the world's largest
cloud investment into these FPG A's and
although right now it's limited
to just tensorflow deployment,
you can try out image classification and
recognition models with it immediately.
The ML workbench is a desktop application
with command line tool support on
windows and Mac.
The entire ml pipeline is
supported including data,
preprocessing model development
and model deployment.
Using the built in Jupiter Notebook
and native get integration.
It makes it easy to get started
when it comes to execution.
The experimentation service supports
the workbench by providing you with the
ability to execute experiments across
a range of compute environment options,
local native, local docker
container, remote docker container,
a spark cluster.
This is where that focus on
hybrid computing Microsoft
has I mentioned earlier
comes into play,
but keep in mind that models need
to be updated over time on new data.
They need to be retrained and sometimes
different versions need to be served.
Two different segments of an audience.
The model management service allows
us to use simple cli commands to
containerize our model and deploy it to
all types of computing environments and
if you do use visual studio,
the tools for AI extension lets you
see a history of past training runs a
gallery of projects and an explorer view
for selecting compute targets for your
script to execute.
But the unique feature about Azure I
find most interesting is the machine
learning studio.
It's a browser based,
visual drag and drop environment
where code isn't even necessary.
It takes you from idea to
deployment in a few clicks.
Let's try out a demo and try to predict
the price of a car in the future.
Using a Dataset of car prices,
our first step will be to
retrieve the relevant Dataset.
We can use one of the sample datasets
included with the studio or import data
from our local machine
drag and drop interface.
Since our data set is
included in the workspace,
we can create a new experiment,
then name it something meaningful.
On the left of the experiment canvas
is a pallet of datasets and modules.
Once we type automobile in the search box,
we'll see our dataset.
We can drag it into
the experiments canvas.
Once there we can visualize
it by selecting the visualize
button on the output.
Port datasets and modules have input
and output ports represented by small
circles and put at the
top output at the bottom.
As we create a data flow,
we'll connect an output port of one
module to an input port of another.
In our sample Dataset,
each sentence of an automobile appears
as a row and the variables associated
with each appear as columns.
The price in the far right column.
That's our target variable
to predict given the rest.
Let's close out of the visualization and
prepare our data for machine learning.
There are some missing values present
in the columns of different rows and the
normalized losses column has a
large proportion of missing values,
so we'll exclude that column
from the model as well.
We'll find these select
columns in Dataset module.
Then drag gets into the experiments
canvas. Once we connect our ports,
we can find the column in
question and remove it swiftly.
Now we can drag the clean missing data
module to the canvas connected to our
select columns module.
Using the remove entire row mode,
we can automate removing rows
that have any missing values.
When that's done running,
we can define what some good
features from our data set would be.
For machine learning.
We can select features for prediction
inside of the select columns in datasets
module.
Now we can set some custom rules,
specifically the features we want to
include that we think are relevant to the
target price of variable when selecting
features for machine learning.
Usually those that we personally would
use to differentiate something are the
ones that tend to be the best features.
Once we've selected that,
we can choose a machine learning algorithm
to apply because we want to predict a
price which is a number, not a category.
We can consider this a regression,
not a classification problem.
We can first split our data into
training and testing datasets.
Then initialize a linear
regression module,
which we can find under
the regression category.
This will create the line of
best fit across our dataset.
Once we click a train model set
our target variable and features,
we can run the experiment.
Once our model is trained,
we can use it to predict new car prices.
We can connect the score model module
to both the train model and split data
modules,
run the experiment and view the
output from the score model module.
It shows the predicted values for price
and the known values from the test data.
From there,
we can iterate to try and improve the
model using different ml algorithms and
deploy it as a predictive web service.
Overall,
[inaudible] is definitely a useful cloud
solution for enterprises and the ML
studio.
Drag and drop interface is a unique
offering that lets entry level developers
intuitively and easily build ml models.
Welcome to the beginning.
I mean the end. Hit subscribe and
I'll love you forever. For now,
how can I try to interview Satya Nadella?
So thanks for watching.